نعم طاهر هنا في ولايه اضنه تشارف عمليات
الانقاذ على النهايه خصوصا ان الجيش
التركي بات مشرفا على بعض المواقع كهذا
الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه الجيش التركي بات
مشرفا على الموقع طبعا بالتعاون مع منظمه
او هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ افاد لكن الجيش
التركي موجودا منذ عده ساعات في هذا
المساء وصلت فرق مختصه تابعه للجيش التركي
تشرف على عمليات ازاله الركام والانقراض
طبعا
العمليات هنا في هذا المبنى الذي نتواجد
فيه بعد اشرف او شارفت على النهايه
مساء هذا اليوم اخبرنا احد المتطوعين الذي
كان يعمل هنا وبعد وصول الجيش انتقل الى
موقع اخر اخبرنا انهم اصبحوا في الطوابق
السفليه تقريبا والعمليه بات اقتربت من
النهايه طبعا نحن اليوم
اصبحنا في يوم الجمعه انتقلنا الى يوم
جديد اليوم الماضي اذا اليوم الخميس صباحا
تم اخراج احد الاشخاص وهو على قيد الحياه
من هذا المبنى بحسب ما علمت من فرق
الانقاذ ان معظم الاحياء او حتى الضحايا
تم انتشالهم من منطقه السلالم او الادراج
عندما كانوا عندما حدث الزلزال هرع السكان
عبر الادراج الى الطوابق السفليه في
محاولتهم للخروج من هذا المبنى الا ان
المبنى مع الاسف انهار بالكامل ولذلك معظم
الجثث التي تم انتشالها او حتى الناجين
الذين تم انتشاؤهم كانوا في منطقه السلالم
او الدرج عندما كانوا
يحاولون الهرب طبعا السلطات او عفوا فرق
الانقاذ يوم امس يعني من خلال حديثنا معهم
كانوا يتوقعون وهو توقع والتكهن وليس رقم
دقيق بوجود 80 شخص في هذا الموقع تحت
الانقاض طبعا انتشروا جثث عديده وتم اخراج
عدد
منهم من الناجين لكن اليوم احد المتطوعين
اخبرني انهم هناك مع الاسف يعني شاهدوا يد
مقطوعه او قدم مقطوعه اجزاء من اجسام لبعض
الضحايا لكن مع ذلك مع ذلك هم لا زالوا
يتعاطون على او يعملون وفق نظريه ان
الجميع احياء لذلك يحاولون وهذا ما يؤخر
عمليات البحث والانقاذ بطبيعه الحال خوف